No corriste. ¿Quieres fumar? Espacito. No corraste.
Me sacan un papel.
Podpisí.
Que yo firme, en blanco.
Ya yo sabía de muchas cosas que eran gente que no quisieron firmar.
¿Viste a mi gente? Sacaron la noche y mandaron para subir.
Allá morían de hambre.
Yo no pensaba nada.
Cuando yo firmo el papel, y yo dejo todo, me agarró un palaco y fui para mi ciudad.
Agarró a mi señora con la hija pequeña que usted ve.
¿Cuándo tuvo su hija?
Ella nació en el año 44.
¿Cuándo? ¿En qué mes?
¿En qué mes?
Septiembre, cumple un año. 52 años.
O sea que su esposa quedó embarazada durante la guerra.
En el búnker.
Sí, señor.
No querer, pasó.
Y septiembre, yo fui de verano, 8 de junio, y ella nació 10 de septiembre.
¿Y cómo fue la llegada al mundo de su hija?
No estaba en mi casa.
Pero después de haber pasado por esta guerra, haber recibido a su hija, ¿cómo fue eso?
Haber recibido a su hija.
Imagínate.
No me imagino, cuénteme.
Imagínate, aquí está bien.
¿Ve usted cuando tenía un año? ¿Lo viste?
Debo daba, agarró un palaco, y yo para Lodz.
Pasaron un día por Varsovia, Varsovia está más lejos que Varsovia,
que yo fui a todas las avenidas, estaban piedras.
El chofer venía a limpiar piedras que podíamos pasar para Lodz.
Y de allá, yo conocí, uno tiene que defenderse, ¿no?
Me conocí a un general, ruso, y hice negocio.
Lodz a Varsovia.
Y Lodz eran marcos alemanes.
Y Varsovia era Zlotopol.
Entonces, allá era más barato que más caro, y hice ese negocio.
Y de allá, quise quedarme en Polonia.
Y habló con un general.
Pagó ya él, ya vendí mi casa en Lodz.
Irme al país de Israel.
Último país de este mundo, el país de Israel.
Entonces, ¿cómo pasé a la frontera?
Me regalaron un cuadro que iban a poner en votos de cárcel.
Pasamos la frontera, ruso, podía pasar, y ya salimos.
Y en ese tiempo que yo pagó el ruso de dedo,
llegó un delegado de Venezuela con papeles,
que yo tenía que irme a Venezuela.
Entonces, no sabía que yo tenía mi señora y hija.
Entonces, dejo los papeles.
Yo no voy, mire, yo tengo mi señora y mi hija.
Inmediatamente hicieron todos los papeles.
Y aquí, en Venezuela, nos dejaron entrar así.
Entonces, yo, mi nombre, no cambió mi nombre en la guerra,
y tampoco no voy a cambiar mi nombre ahorita.
Y llegó, como usted ve, la sábana.
Hay rica, hay sabor.
No cambió yo mi nombre.
Señor Isaac, usted me dijo que fue a Majdanek.
¿En qué momento fue a Majdanek? ¿En qué año?
Yo digo usted, cuando fui elebrado, en el año 44.
¿Ahí mismo fue a Majdanek?
Inmediatamente.
¿Para qué?
A ver, mire, los rusos entraron allá.
A mí, elebraron los rusos.
Lublin fui elebrado por rusos.
Eran 70 kilómetros.
Inmediatamente se fue a ver.
Nosotros ya sabíamos que allá había crecido el crematorio.
Y usted explicó cómo se lo cortaron.
Huesos y todo, mire, como era el crematorio,
rodondo, ¿está me entiende?
Diferente que en su libro.
¿Quería ver lo que había pasado?
¿Seguro?
Allá se lo cortaron todo.
Chiba, ¿sabes qué es Chiba?
Quédese sentado, señor Ray.
Que es, se meta y se saca, ¿está me entiende?
Camillas.
Sí.
Sí, sí, sí, lo entiendo.
Rodondo, era.
Ya se lo cortaron todo, polvo, huesos, mire, todo, mire.
Allá, mire, cortaron ese túnel de los huertos
y adonde mataron a esos siete que manejaban el crematorio.
Y así me vi de persona venezolana.
Muy duro.
¿Cómo fue la llegada a Venezuela?
Muy pobre.
Cuando pasé en Valencia por Calle Pais,
no tenía una noche para comprar un pancito.
Sí, ¿qué iba a pasar?
Estoy brincando.
Llegó a Estocolmo, llegó.
Estaba seis meses en Estocolmo.
¿Cómo fue en Estocolmo?
Estocolmo, yo tenía mucho dinero,
no me quitaron antes de irse.
Controlaron, mire, tanto que te quitaron zapatos,
suelos de zapatos controlados.
Usted me perdone, tengo que decirte una cosa
que me da pena decir.
En un plástico yo metí 500 dólares atrás, adentro.
Y con 500 dólares yo llego a Estocolmo.
¿No qué era?
Que llegaban después de la guerra,
ayudaban mucho.
Llegaron, nos mandaron nosotros para un hacendado
y yo comida baratísima.
Ya yo mando una carta a mi hermano que está en Estocolmo.
Yo tenía visa, transit, New York, a Venezuela.
No se conseguió con quien ir,
no por aviones y no por barcos.
Tenía suerte que me conocí con un capitán
que era barco que se llamaba Express California
que en Estocolmo buscaban camburos en Colombia.
Entonces fueron 12 personas en ese barquito
que me vinieron para Aruba.
En Aruba me recibieron, mire, cumpliendo honores.
Ya sabían toda mi vida.
De aquí ya dijeron que yo esperaba en barco.
Cuando me llegaron con ese barquito,
mi señora estaba en estado de enfermedad.
Ella dijo un parche sin...
Ella acostó con un bisecteta y cayó
y el niño estaba perdido.
Entonces yo marcamente los dedos se portaban, mire,
mejor que por echar.
Hablaron perfecto alemán.
Entonces me dijeron así, ¿qué quieres tú?
¿O tu señora o tu hija?
Digo, yo quiero ambos.
Es como que no es la pregunta.
Hablan alemán, yo no hablo.
Es verdad.
Me fui para casa con mi corazón
y me dejaron en manos de médicos.
Después me mandaron que yo venga urgentemente.
Mi corazón.
Vengo urgentemente.
Dice, mire, estamos cinco médicos.
Tú eres el sexto médico.
Vamos a hacer
tras contra tras.
Yo no soy médico, como puede ser.
Tú eres más que médico.
Que tú puedes sobrevivir la guerra.
Tú tienes gran poder.
Tienes que hacer.
Entonces, tres eran a favor.
Aguantar, salvar la hija.
Y dos eran en contra.
Entonces yo era con esos tres.
Y gracias a Dios, usted puede ver,
que ahorita viene usted a ver, mire, quién yo salvó
y cómo yo sobreviví.
Esa es la historia.
Todavía es muy largo.
Pero ya...
Ya estamos terminando.
Usted llegó a Venezuela.
¿A qué ciudad?
Valencia.
¿Por qué a Valencia?
Porque vivía mi hermano allá.
Yo llego y estuve tres días aquí.
Tengo que explicar muchas cosas, mire,
que no la noche y no mañana explicarte, mire,
cómo, cómo la cosa, mire.
Ya pues son en Venezuela cuñaderos.
Así.
Y nadie no puede decir en Venezuela
que yo pillo algo que me prestó en Bolívar.
Yo tenía aquí gentes,
que padres de ellos que estaban en, en, en, en,
afuera del gueto.
Primero a Dios yo mantenía.
Y las cartas me escribieron
que yo sobrevivía.
Y vengo para acá.
A mitad que ellos quieren,
a mitad para mí.
Yo estoy orgulloso
que no me ayudaron nada.
Y gracias.
Y yo soy yo.
¿Y la gente le preguntaba
qué es lo que había pasado en Europa, en Polonia?
Cuando usted llegó, ¿le preguntaban qué pasó?
Ya sabían todo.
¿Y usted contaba lo que le pasó?
Nada.
¿Por qué?
Pues ya sabían todo, mire.
¿Qué yo voy a contar, mire?
Yo estoy contando a usted
que si quiere para historia,
más si uno quiere hablar,
que viene otra gente y me quiere preguntar,
yo no sé nada.
¿Cómo lo trató la gente de Venezuela?
Venezolanos mejor que judíos.
Es otra historia.
Tengo que dejarla.
Eso le iba a preguntar
cómo lo trató también la gente de la comunidad judía.